if you just bought a steam deck and are
wondering what to boot up first we've
rounded up a few of the best games to
play on it including major aaa hits
under the radar indies and everything in
between in most cases these games have
already been declared as deck verified
by valve meaning it's fully supported
we've also personally tested all of the
games on this list however so even in
cases where things do come with caveats
like needing to use the touch screen
momentarily to log into xbox in one
example we find the games themselves
outweigh these minor hiccups and still
recommend them as a result with that
said let's dive into the list
elden ring eldon rings the lands between
our vast and rich with activities to
undertake at any given moment you're a
stone's throw away from a hidden dungeon
a brand new area of the map or a
challenging mini boss although the game
tells you to seek the shards of the
elden ring and become the elden lord
it's easy to spend dozens of hours doing
other things instead the steam deck is a
fantastic way of undertaking some of
these shorter tasks in bite-sized chunks
before returning to the main task at
hand on a bigger screen with a beefier
pc steam's ability to seamlessly upload
and download cloud saves makes this
functionality a breeze as well but if
you're playing entirely on the steam
deck alden ring runs very well no doubt
because valve took steps to ensure the
biggest game of the year which launched
around the same time as its steam deck
actually worked eldering looks and plays
excellent on the handheld so you can hop
into the lands between whenever is most
convenient for you
[Music]
spirit fairer spirit fair is unlike any
other farm life sim you've played for
starters its farm is actually a boat
moving through the underworld which
reminds us of another key difference
that you're dead as the operator of the
underworld's ferry you'll meet
characters help resolve their unfinished
business then wave them goodbye as they
coast into the everlight some
unspecified what comes after space
all the while there's plenty of recipes
to learn items to craft plants to
harvest and more your list of duties and
quests is long so you'll have plenty to
do over the course of many on the go
sessions with the game just know that
passengers aboard your train plane or
bus may catch you drying your eyes
hitman 3 hitman 3 is the culmination of
a half decade of hard work from i o
interactive and that's admirable but
also on steam deck it's a diverse world
tour of portable murder playgrounds and
that's pretty neat too don't you think
if you happen to have access to the
earlier games in the hitman reboot
series this third game houses every
level weapon and ridiculous costume into
one central hub giving hitman fans the
totality of the franchise's best entries
all in the palms of their hands
disco elysium disco elysium is so text
heavy that it can feel like you're
actually holding a kindle when playing
it on a steam deck but for fans of deep
rpg experiences it's exactly what you're
probably looking for the latitude for
true role-playing is vast and the story
goes places that are both smart and
unpredictable the painterly art style
also looks great in handheld mode and
may have fellow trained passengers
looking over to see what it is you're
doing which admittedly is a little
awkward when you start the game hung
over in your underpants you really
dropped the ball harry
final fantasy pixel remasters the
classic final fantasy series has gotten
lovingly restored with the pixel
remaster but its other available
platform is less than ideal the mobile
versions lack a lot of the customization
options that you'll find on pc and they
don't even support controllers so you're
forced to use
touch controls but these classic rpgs
feel ready made for portable making
steam deck the best place to play not
only can you grind levels while binge
watching a show but it looks and plays
great and you can even install mods to
for example fix the font but if you can
only get one final fantasy 6 is an
absolute masterpiece
[Music]
god of war some games fit steam deck
because their genre or gameplay elements
just feel right at home in the handheld
device others like god of war are just
proof of how powerful the steam deck
really is god of war is a game that once
seemed unlikely to ever come to pc but
in 2022 not only is it available on the
platform it's fully verified and ready
to go on steam deck it's so cool to see
it in this way it almost makes one wish
for some sort of playstation handheld
device like a portable playstation or
some sort of the v
v vitta
something like that
left 4 dead 2.
few game scream valve more than left 4
dead 2 so it should be a no-brainer for
the steam deck and i'm happy to report
that playing it on the handheld is
actually even better than playing it on
console it runs incredibly smooth and
the pc lobbies have always stayed active
even after the xbox community largely
fell by the wade side fairweather fans
if you ask me the controls are simple
too so even if you've been playing for
years on pc you'll quickly intuit how to
pick up an axe and start chopping off
zombie limbs with friends on the go
monster train much like slay the spire
which clearly inspired it monster train
is a game well suited to quick bursts of
gameplay because it's already available
on xbox it features controller support
so controlling it on deck is easy but
just as importantly the action is
readable on the screen and its turn
based nature lends itself to the type of
portable toilet gaming that deck enables
however you play it though the gameplay
remains some of the very best in the
roguelike deck builder genre giving you
a great deal of freedom in how you
assemble your deck and combine cards
from different factions to make each run
feel distinct
[Music]
children of morta i like to think of
children of morta as an underappreciated
gem in the dungeon crawler genre in it
you play as the pixelated burgenson
family each member of which has their
own unique fighting style and weaponry
clearing out damp and dark caves around
your immaculate home is made more
engrossing thanks to a fantastic
narrator he does carry you off into a
fantasy world on even the most tedious
bus ride to work
rogue legacy 2. this anticipated sequel
has finally gotten a full release after
an extended early access period and it
might just be the ideal use case for
steam deck the roguelite action game has
you once again battling through a castle
as a cascading series of heirs each with
their own powers making incremental
progress all the way as you inherit new
traits and buy permanent upgrades the
new 2d 3d hybrid art style looks
fantastic on the steam deck screen and
it's the perfect type of easy to pick up
hard to put down experience that thrives
on a handheld
sable if switch players get breath of
the wild at least steam deck users get
to have sable this clearly breath of the
wild inspired open world puzzler
foregoes combat of any kind in favor of
a chilled out coming-of-age story set in
a unique fantasy world full of quests
characters and secrets the open-ended
game lets you see its credits in as
little as 3 hours or as many as 20 plus
it's up to you to decide when your ride
is over be that when your flight ends or
perhaps months down the line the music
is done entirely by japanese breakfast
too giving the entire game a meditative
quality that is perfect for a long trip
you may not otherwise be looking forward
to
of thieves while you do need an internet
connection to play sea of thieves so
this one isn't great for your commute
that isn't too hard to come by in 2022
past iterations of rare's pirate sandbox
have been less short session friendly
but the team has taken strides to
improve the game in that area offering
short and sweet daily challenges for all
players and introducing new seaforts
which are meant to be challenged in one
in as little as 15 to 20 minutes
including the time it takes to sell all
your loot sea of thieves like god of war
is the kind of game that you once could
only dream about playing on a handheld
but today the future has arrived
by boat
and with pirates
but it's still the future
unpacking unpacking is another one of
those games that feels welcoming to
short or long play sessions alike in
this 2021 wordless wonder from which
beam you learn about unseen characters
just by unpacking their boxes on various
moving days spread across their life
from childhood into much older age the
point-and-click nature of the game is
welcoming to the steam deck's multiple
input modes including analog sticks or
the touchscreen
valheim if you didn't play valheim when
it first blew up in 2021 or even if you
did it makes a great steam deck game in
large part that's due to the way it's
friendly to both short and long play
sessions chop down a few trees and work
on building your home in the early hours
or party up with friends and take on the
game's most unfriendly beasts many hours
later whether you're new to the viking
survival game or think you've scoured
every inch of the sandbox seeing it on
the steam deck can feel like arriving in
a whole new
world
vampire survivors an early access game
you can grab on the cheap vampire
survivors is very simple but shockingly
fun the single stick shooter has you
navigate around hordes of enemies while
your weapons fire off automatically
building up experience to buy new weapon
upgrades the deceptively simple premise
gets increasingly fiendish and chaotic
as more enemies join the fray and your
weapon upgrades get even more
destructive it's enough to tempt you to
play just one more round until you
realize oh whoops it's 3am and you have
a video to edit in the morning
the witcher 3. whenever you can take one
of the best rpgs in the world with you
on the go you gotta do it the witcher 3
is also playable on switch but it looks
and runs much better on steam deck in
our personal experience though the game
is now 7 years old dear god it's still a
benchmark in video game storytelling
especially when it comes to those
incredible side quests and also those
incredible abs exploring the world
meeting colorful characters and slaying
monsters makes any train ride or long
trip so much more interesting
the banner saga trilogy the original
banner saga was one of the first games
that some of us here at gamespot
installed on our steam deck and what a
debut it was the tactical rpg and
part-time nordic-styled oregon trail is
still a lovely experience so many years
since launch the former mass effect
writers on the team helped breathe life
into a new cast of characters whom
you'll be glad to take with you wherever
you go the first two games are already
deck verified while the third one is yet
to be tested by valve but it plays as
intended for us
into the breach for our money into the
breach is one of the best design games
in recent memory and it's perfectly at
home on the steam deck thanks to its
turn-based nature and bite-sized
missions as the previous switch release
demonstrated the controls work perfectly
well with a gamepad and the screen here
is well up to the task of displaying all
the information you need performance is
fantastic i mean it's not a terribly
demanding game from any hardware
perspective and it's a terrific time
that you can sink hours into or
occasionally glance at while watching
something on tv
ori and the blind forest the
metroidvania genre fits like a glove on
steam deck and among those our favorite
is the ori series while we haven't
tested the sequel ori and the will of
the wisps the original remains an
immaculate and tightly designed genre
standout arguably the best of the past
decade taking that on the go is already
possible on switch and even xbox cloud
gaming so you've maybe had opportunities
to play it in handheld mode before but
if you missed it until now the steam
deck is the best of these handhelds
thanks to it not requiring an internet
connection like xbox and its larger
nicer screen than switch
res infinite steam deck passes a very
important test that we here at gamespot
have to determine how good any gaming
platform is which is
can you play res on it the answer is
thankfully yes and it does so well res
infinite runs quite smoothly and its
straightforward control scheme
translates well to the dex pad the
relatively short nature of each level
makes it easy to jump in and out of on
deck and even with the system's
relatively limited battery life you can
still play through everything here
without needing to plug in while you're
better off plugging in some headphones
to fully appreciate the killer
soundtrack it still sounds good coming
out of the speakers this is an
incredible experience and a must-have on
deck
totally accurate battle simulator
there's no shortage of ragdoll brawlers
as of late but totally accurate battle
simulator is the best of them in a very
crude way it almost plays like age of
empires or other deep strategy games
you'll set up your army of various
fighters spanning centuries of human
history and prepare to take on
formidable foes on the other side of the
battlefield but the lucy goosey googly
eyed warriors make it all so silly and
the one more try design is perfect for a
portable platform like steam deck
soma this list would feel incomplete
without a horror game on it soma from
frictional games the team that also made
the incredible insomnia series is one of
the finest horror games and stories
you'll find on steam deck and it's fully
verified as well they say the best
setting for a horror game is where the
lights are off and the headphones are on
and the portability of the steam deck
means you can go find that setting for
yourself even when your pc itself may
not have allowed it otherwise so this is
the perfect game to play underneath your
blanket if you don't intend to sleep
ever again
[Music]
half-life 2. half-life 2 being great on
steam deck is basically a given
considering valve's long-term support of
the 2004 game valve likes to use it and
games like portal as testing grounds and
showcases for its new technology and
there are some steam deck bells and
whistles that make the already fantastic
landmark first person shooter shine on
deck gordon freeman's second adventure
still looks and plays great more than 15
years later but the default control
setup also incorporates motion controls
using dex captive tech simply laying
your thumb on the right control stick
activates the motion controls setting it
up this way means you only use the
motion when you are aiming a bit like
breath of the wild's default controls
and it allows you to play it like a
standard controller fps game without
diving into menus if you choose using
motion control to take out head crabs is
a feature we never knew we wanted but
immediately found ourselves using and
enjoying on steam deck
now if only we could get half-life 3 on
steam deck or you know
anywhere else
and that's our list for the best games
to play on steam deck and it can even
run crysis too but of course we couldn't
get every game that works on the steam
deck so tell us what you're playing in
the comments below because we're always
looking for more suggestions for future
lists and if you're still trying to
figure out everything you can about
steam deck before you dive in check out
our video on everything to know about
the steam deck with all that said though
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss all of our coverage of the steam
deck and everything else right here on
gamespot
[Music]